[Music]
[Applause]
I was walking in the street
we heard a phone call we
turned around we saw people
running from right to left and after 5 6
minutes after me I saw that there are
people because I already know who
work at the hairdressing salon we
entered the salon
and there are three injured people in the salon
after I was asked to call the
fire department I called
I called the police to say that
there are injured
[Music] to
interest him was already known to the
judicial services since he has
both antecedents even if the search
for antecedents continues with I only
communicate to you what
I know following my transport to
the scene
[Music]